now to a story that affects tens of
millions of american families an
expanded version of the child tax credit
is set to expire next month after
congress failed to reach a deal to
extend it jan crawford is in washington
with the potential impact on those
people who are getting that money jan
this could really
be an unwelcome surprise yeah i mean
jamie it's going to be a big change for
a lot of families i mean of course there
was a tax credit before the pandemic but
it was for less money it went to fewer
families it was only paid out during tax
season so this temporary child tax
credit has been going out every month
since july some 35 million eligible
families have been able to get up to 300
a month per child
so the program was paying parents a
total of up to thirty six hundred
dollars per child six and under and up
to three thousand for each child up to
age seventeen and of course it expanded
who qualified so when west virginia
senator joe manchin said he wouldn't
support the build better bill that also
killed a provision in that bill that
would have extended the expansion
through 2022 that was needed because
according to columbia university
payments were cutting child poverty
rates by nearly 30 percent in october
alone
now it's not clear if lawmakers are
going to be able to come up with a
compromise on this child tax credit but
with no deal there
obviously there's going to be a gap in
those monthly payments which means more
uncertainty for those family budgets in
the new year nate yeah we'll keep our
eye on it as we head into the new year
jan thank you so much